Some people worry that big tech
companies are seducing you into spending
more time online, all so they can monetize
your data. Is this true? Yes, but not in a
bad way! Big tech companies do try to get
you to consume more of their services,
just like Starbucks and the New York
Times do. This is normal. Is consuming
more tech bad for you?
Studies show that spending more time on
Facebook is associated with greater
obesity, less well being, and less real
time with friends. But this is also true
for television. And if you interact with
your friends on Facebook, your sense of
well-being is actually higher, and you
feel more socially connected. But don't
the tech companies gather lots of data
on you that they use to their advantage?
Absolutely, but this is also normal.
President Obama made social media micro-targeting of voters famous. Tech
companies just need to be transparent
about their real business. Big tech is
doing what others have done before, only
in a bigger way, and big tech's successors
will do it even bigger.
What do you think?
Does big tech know too much about you?
Let us know your comments. Also, let us
know what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds, and be
sure to like and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.